todo empezó el 7 de mayo de 2022 en
mitad de la madrugada los ataques rusos
llegaron a Back mood y no han cesado
desde entonces varios edificios quedaron
reducidos a cenizas y muchos civiles
resultaron heridos A mediados de junio
mientras su cráneo intentaba plantar
cara los ataques rusos los bombardeos
siguieron y forzaron a mucha gente
abandonar la ciudad donde debería ir
dónde debería dormir
y no está claro cuando Habrá más
bombardeos si habrá más explosiones en
la noche pero la situación no había
escalado del todo hasta Julio
cuando Rusia bombardeó tres de
asentamientos en la zona con un número
desconocido de civiles muertos y heridos
Y es que badmud es un punto estratégico
en esta guerra perteneciente a adoníes
que en el don Bass tomar la ciudad
afianzaría el control ruso en la región
que ya declara como suya desde
septiembre pero lo cierto Es que badmud
se le ha resistido a Rusia y también a
Ucrania convirtiéndolo en uno de los
puntos más sangrientos de la guerra pero
dónde me voy a ir mi hija murió en la
cantera un proyectil alcanzó mi casa
no iré a ningún sitio no la he enterrado
aún sigue ahí bajo los escombros no
puedo lo siento
en septiembre los rusos atacaron 11
localidades cerca del frente y más gente
decidió irse de la ciudad de los 70.000
que eran antes de la guerra Sólo quedan
cerca de Diez mil
con combates incesantes en diciembre la
ofensiva rusa se intensificó y los
civiles que aún están allí tuvieron que
celebrar la Navidad entre bombardeos
ahora la situación no es mejor con
ataques diarios el 13 de enero Rusia se
hizo con el control de soledad en las
afueras de bakmuth su primera Gran
Victoria en la zona en un año que ahora
amenaza con llegar hasta ba